the midterm exam is now on course works
it is under syllabus for session 10 or
week 10 and it says Oh take-home essay
all the instructions are there the
materials you need and it will be due on
the day that it states that it is to be
due which I don't actually remember but
18th yes
18th doing the 18th the chapter that you
are to be reading for this week is on
pre-columbian civilizations in the
Americas there was a taste of this in an
earlier chapter because of poor
conceptualization from the part of the
authors as to how to group topics so I
haven't really talked about
pre-columbian America before now and in
fact this is the first lecture I've ever
given on pre-columbian America in any
context
it's an area that is quite different
from the ones that historians are more
comfortable with for parts of the world
that have very little written history
such as sub-saharan Africa Southeast
Asia Australia they also have fairly
meager archaeological findings up to
this point and therefore it seems like
the traditional approach of historians
using printed sources is compounded by a
lack of material sources when you come
to pre-columbian America you have got a
complete absence of written sources
because you did have Richard languages
developing late in the pre-columbian
period and then you had the things that
were written by the by the Spaniards in
the Portuguese when they came and others
nevertheless for the earlier phases of
pre-columbian
history there are no written sources but
there are you know enormous reservoirs
of archaeological material
archaeologists and historians do not
always play well together I was recently
reading an article dealing with this
part of the world by a an English
historian who said that in England
archaeology grew up as a part of history
it sort of dealt with the earlier phases
of history or the the material
concomitant of some historical
development but that in America it grew
up as part of anthropology and in his
view anthropologists and historians
don't see the world through the same
optic and this is sort of embodied in
the phrase absence of evidence is not
evidence of absence for archaeologists
there is a strong tendency to say if we
have not found something it wasn't there
for historians they often say if we
haven't found anything yet it doesn't
mean it wasn't there
it simply means it may have been
perishable and they have been so poorly
distributed that we haven't happened
onto something
but we shouldn't count it out simply
because we haven't found it yet and here
you have a tendency of historians to
make comparative appraisals saying well
X exists in this parallel configuration
in some other area therefore it probably
existed in this you know in this other
area for pre-columbian America whether
or not archaeology really is quite the
iron trap that it appears to be you have
a compounding of things by the more
recent use of materials that are not in
the first order archaeological such as
computer simulations DNA net DNA
analyses and the like where you may you
may work from a from a datum or some
collection of data and and then handle
these data through means that are not
typical of
of historians or even for the earlier
generations of archaeologists this comes
up in a number of kind of test cases the
first of which is the theory of
megafauna extinctions in the 1960s this
was a theory that hit the academic world
as kind of a bombshell sort of like the
more or less contemporary theory of the
extinction of the dinosaurs being caused
by a an asteroid impact megafauna the
term megafauna it refers to big animals
you could say that megafauna extinction
is about big animal extinction but why
would you say big animal when you can
say megafauna and and you know give a
little a little hint of exoticism and
mystery to what's actually a fairly
simple idea or observation namely that
in many parts of the world animals that
are big and these people define big
pretty precisely
it'll be like say over 100 kilos or
bigger than you and me of course bigger
than me is hard but the so we're talking
about biggest animals and it's been
observed that they have disappeared in
different parts of the world and that in
a very very rough equation they seem to
disappear right around the time the
first humans show up so for Australia
where the big animals in Australia seem
to disappear maybe 40,000 years ago and
humans may have shown up around the same
time
there is the thought well maybe the
humans killed all the animals for the
Caribbean islands the big animals
disappeared 5,000 years ago and that's
thought to be roughly when the first
Native Americans settled in the
Caribbean islands for islands in
different parts of the world it is
fairly easy to ascertain that big
animals are killed by humans the most
notorious case of course isla dodo a
large flightless bird on the island of
Mauritius which was absolutely delicious
apparently and so you know once the
island of Mauritius was found you would
have European ships that would stop
there kill themselves a whole larder
full of Dodos you know pack them in salt
put him on board and then eat dodo for a
lot and family got their fun there were
no no does left and so the island where
she still has the dodo on its on its
coat of arms and of course of rising sea
levels are may soon be no island where
as was left but but for what is true of
an island is much harder to affirm with
respect to a to a continent so when the
when the big animals disappeared from
Australia the idea that they were
eliminated by the humans using
Paleolithic killing implements seemed to
be a stretch to some people and seem to
be self-evident for other people because
otherwise why would you have a
correlation and time now you get to the
new world I'm not going to talking about
Australia here when you get to the
Western Hemisphere to the new world of
the period of the megafauna extinction
so the time when the big animals
disappeared seems to be at the end of
the last ice age
very roughly around fourteen thousand
years ago or twelve thousand BC and lo
and behold that is when humans arrived
unless the humans arrived a lot earlier
and this has been a problem in that
there have been numerous archaeological
sites in different parts of both North
and South America that have been
suggestive of the idea that humans
arrived well before fourteen thousand
years ago but there is nothing that has
been confirmed
these are usually sites where you will
have an assemblage of stones that in one
person's eyes looks like a pile of
stones when a person's eyes it looks
like a pile of human crafted implements
but in terms of dateable material it's
hard to it's hard to come up with a firm
case of substantially earlier human
settlement but if of course the human
settlement was earlier than the the
correlation of the three big animal
extinctions obviously fails what were
the big animals
mastodons who are relatives of mammoths
which are relatives of elephants were a
North American species that disappeared
the giant ground sloth disappeared
horses and camels disappeared not not
huge animals by comparison with a
mastodon or a giant ground sloth but big
enough to fall into the big animal
category saber-tooth cats disappeared
you can make up a list of the big
animals who disappeared
that will numerate you know dozens of
species but there were big animals that
did not disappear so that bison did not
disappear moose did not disappear
caribou did not disappear Jaguars did
not disappear papers in South America
did not disappear the camelids of South
America the llamas the wanna costa wanna
coast actually the wanna close primarily
that of the wild species did not
disappear so the people who have argued
for the extinction of big animals by
humans have also faced the issue of why
some species and not others their
alternative the well let's let's think
the over kill theory in order to make
that work people who back that theory
did computer simulations they said that
if people entered let us say you know
January 1st 14,000 years ago and they
extended their habitable area at a
certain rate of so many kilometers per
year they would have had enough time in
this extension to kill every living
thing that they encountered if they were
so inclined to do it this is where the
comparative examples become sort of a
test you know why would humans have
wanted to kill
all of the big animals why would they
have done that by the time you get to
14,000 years ago human art has already
developed quite a bit so that you think
of the cave paintings that you have in
southern France or northern Spain and
you see that humans were perfectly able
to to represent the animals that lived
in their environments but they don't in
fact you know and there are many many
assemblages of petroglyphs that is to
say stone paintings or carvings in the
Americas but they don't show giant
ground sloths and mastodons and
saber-toothed Tigers and so forth in
other words the animals that they were
alleged to be bent on killing to the
point of extinction don't show up in
their imaginary and that that seems to
be a contradiction from historians point
of view you'd say well you know it's
precisely the animals that were hunted
that seemed to show up in in Europe in
the Mesolithic and Paleolithic and here
the animals that show up are moose
caribou a bighorn sheep bison of the
animals that show up with the animals
that we know historically were around in
order to support the overkill theory
there has been it's been hypothesized
that people learned through the use of
fire to Stampede animals into perilous
places where the earlier a boxed into a
canyon or they ran over a cliff and died
and you know I'm from the Middle West
you go a long long long way looking for
a cliff that that an animal can't scram
now you know how they kill every animal
in Nebraska is hard to do but of course
they did
Nebraska was full of bison they didn't
kill them yeah well this of course was
the problem that now you have a lot of
dead animals and presumably what you do
then is you dance you done do one of
these big animal kill dances and that's
it there have been a total of 14 locales
where human remains have been found in
conjunction with Mastodon remains no
other large animal has been has been
found in conjunction with human remains
in a context that suggests a killing so
so this is one of these cases where is
the absence of evidence the evidence of
absence the people who favor the
overkill theory says well you know you
never really find you know
archaeologically you never find an
animal that has a you know somebody's
written on the on the antler you know
killed my John Doe and such-and-such a
date kill sites are not normal and
therefore if you don't find any up
doesn't mean anything at all you know
absence of evidence is not evidence of
absence
on the other hand when you look at the
distribution of population you really do
find yourself puzzled as to how a in
sparsely inhabited areas you know the
animals disappear seemingly more than in
the densely inhabited areas so when you
get down to South America and Central
America where you have Jaguars and so
forth a denser population than you would
have in the great plains of United
States and yet the animals remained
obviously I'm not a fan of the overkill
theory Jared Diamond is if you've read
Guns Germs and Steel
is one of a series of bad judgment calls
I think that he made in that book
because he compounded the problem he
didn't he didn't simply rely on the
computer simulations or the chance
archaeological finds but rather he said
that the animals of the American that
the humans found and they came to the
Americans were not familiar with humans
and therefore they didn't know enough to
be afraid
they haven't seen aliens they didn't
know that you know alien beings are
going to kill you if you if you don't
watch out whereas the animals in the old
world which humans failed to exterminate
of course they did exterminate the
mammoths perhaps but they didn't
exterminate the great herds of animals
in Africa or you know the Eurasian
steppe or something his argument is well
those animals really knew that humans
are dangerous and therefore they do to
run away be afraid be very afraid and
and you know plausibility to it until
you you think well this is what got the
scientists Lamarck in trouble by saying
that you have the inheritance of
acquired characteristics because the you
know no animal of any species including
humans has ever seen a human until
they're born so that their appraisal of
a human for good or ill is something
that they acquire in the course of their
lifetime but the doctrine that is
generally accepted in evolutionary
theory that you cannot pass on my
inheritance an acquired characteristic
would say that supposing you've learned
to be afraid of people you'll learn that
and you can't pass it on to your
offspring genetically now you could pass
it on culturally conceive in other words
you could school your your your Cubs or
your foals or your offspring to be
afraid of humans but
is also assuming that humans have a
certain a certain cominis in the
landscape and there's a question of the
degree to which non-human species have a
cultural context to pass on and so forth
and but even then it's very hard to see
a to imagine mama and papa
saber-tooth Tiger saying in the Cubs you
know be aware of the humans and as
opposed to saying humans because some of
the animals that were exterminator very
very dangerous animals the direwolf li
saber-toothed cats and so on so diamond
goes with sort of a Lamarckian theory
and he says the reason that the caribou
and the bison and primarily caribou and
bison the moose do not the reason is
that they survive is that you had them
in Europe and that therefore they
presumably you know sent telegrams ahead
saying you know people coming warning
folks coming into your territory be
aware of them okay lampooning Jared
Diamond's one of my favorite activities
but I'll stop there because I know I've
done enough to get the point across
there are other theories there's a
theory that illness killed off the big
animals maybe the humans brought the
illness with them but nobody's found any
pathogen that would support that idea
there's the idea that there was a
climate change what's known as the
lesser dry-ass of the Younger Dryas
period a brief period of reglaze EA ssin
brief meaning few hundred years but then
it's argued that well these are species
that lived through the
the real the bad ice age why were they
just gonna you know flop over and die in
a kind of just 200 years of renewed cold
weather so there's the idea that you
know you have over kill over ill over
chill and I just I just picked this up
on a website I thought was gonna need
and the other one didn't work too well
but it was anyway it had to do with the
idea that there must have been a comet
or an asteroid that blew up in the air
and and killed the ball all right
we don't have a foggiest idea what
happened to the big animals we have
theories but that a fortiori goes for
pretty much everything else in
pre-columbian America we don't generally
know what happened and usually in you
know in a particular level we know even
less and therefore it is open to
theories em two and two competing
theories when you read a chapter on
pre-columbian America of the sort that
you read in my book or pretty much in
any of the competing world history books
you find that the Western Hemisphere is
treated as a separate a sort of a
self-contained part of the planetary
past now you could argue I suppose that
being surrounded by oceans that separate
these continents by thousands miles from
others warrants this separation but if
you take a comparative view and you look
at that from a global perspective you
begin to ask questions that that aren't
always asked that much in the ancient
Mediterranean world there was a idea put
forward by the the geographer ptolemy
and supported in the somewhat different
form by Aristotle and then picked up by
Arab and Persian writers the idea that
the the world is a sphere a globe and it
is divided into a series of climbs
usually seven climbs for Ptolemy for
Aristotle as five climbs but you have
the idea that you have these bands that
characterize the globe at certain you
know certain levels of remove from from
the equator with you equator coming
along here these climbs will then be
characterized and the most common
characterization of the equatorial climb
and here the middle climb is that it is
uninhabitable or near to it and this is
borne out by various speculations of the
closer you get to the equator people are
burned Brown by the Sun and you have no
civilization as you get into areas that
are too hot so forth and so on and then
when you get up here that's just too
cold so you don't have any thing there
so it's the the temperate zones north
and south that theoretically is where
you have civilization and as luck would
have it Ptolemy and Aristotle both lived
in such a temperate zone and therefore
they thought that this was fairly
self-evident and indeed it has been
taken almost as self-evident by
historians of ourselves
that is to say down at the present day
when people look at the tropics they say
well we don't find civilization or
widespread agriculture or such and such
here or there in the tropics because
they are the tropics and where we look
for the origins of everything worthwhile
is in the temperate zones but then when
you look at the Americas it flips the
the civilizational developments in the
Americas how to say the ones that
culminate from the point of view of the
European in comer in coming peoples in
the Aztecs of Mexico and the Incas of
Peru these civilizations are all in the
equatorial zone and the temperate zones
are sparsely populated have a much a
much lower level of of material culture
do not develop written languages do not
seem to develop to the same degree the
urban arts and and characteristics that
you have in the tropical or the
equatorial zone and when you do find
them
these sorts of developments you can
usually trace them back to a
dissemination from the equatorial zone
that is to say you can you know early
Indian or Native American remains in
southern Florida attributed to the
Colusa people are have aspects that
appear to represent a dissemination of
cultural practices from the Maya who are
in Mexico
Billy's Honduras so forth in Central
America same thing for the the earliest
quasi urbanized peoples in the American
Southwest the Anasazi in the southwest
they have characteristics that are
thought to disseminate from the
equatorial zone now by I thought to
disseminate this is course an
archaeological judgment where you find
ceramic elements or architectural
elements or pictorial elements and you
try to see where they might come from
but there are more concrete signs of
dissemination and this has to do with
the spread of of crops and in particular
the great cereal of the new world maize
or corn which spreads in up to North
America and spreads south into South
America from some point of of
development in Central America or
perhaps in Mexico proper so we know that
that things did move you know when it
comes to to foodstuffs and cultivation
the degree to which other cultural
aspects moved this is more debatable but
going back to this question of why does
this happen in the in the equatorial
zone when you look at parallel
Equatorial zones as I said in Africa or
Southeast Asia in particular it's hard
to see
why the Central American area stands out
now a comparison has been made between
the lowland Mayan civilization nope
you know Mexico comes down here and it
has a big Peninsula it sets up that's
the Yucatan Peninsula and then you know
give the rest of Central America so you
have el Salvador Guatemala Honduras
Belize state of Yucatan hapless state
and so forth and the lowland Maya are
the ones here in the yucca town this
this is mostly mountainous down here in
Guatemala and El Salvador Honduras the
the earliest civilization was over here
on the on the west coast the Olmecs and
many of the cultural characteristics of
the Maya seemed to come from from the
earlier Olmecs in people who've tried to
put together my own chronology we'll
talk about a population moving into the
look the Mayan lowlands somewhere 2000
1000 BC and then you'll get a classic
maam stuff you know in let's say after
two or three hundred eighty in other
words that say the long period of
development you know it seems as though
there were no human inhabitants in the
lowland by an area they'll prior to this
to this migration what this does to the
notion of big animal extinction if you
have areas that humans didn't get to
you'd think hey all the big animals will
go there and just hang out because there
are humans around but
the comparison that's been made is
between the Mayan lowlands and
southeastern Nigeria which is where the
the ebo people live these soils are very
similar the rainfall and temperature
patterns are are quite similar
including what months you get maximum
precipitation and so forth the crops
they grow are similar in the sense that
they are primarily you know root crops
yams and you know yams in Nigeria and
manioc Oh cassava in the Maya territory
plus was a grain it would be maize in
the New World and sorghum in the old and
so you know that the the questions asked
if you have exactly similar conditions
in this equatorial zone do you need to
to explain why one generates a major
civilization you know I'm talking
pyramids and you know human sacrifice
and all those things that we associate
with major civilizations where whereas
another gradually you know moves from
slash-and-burn agriculture toward local
garden agriculture big deal I mean it
you know why is there a dissimilarity
you could take take other comparisons
you can take going farther south the
coastal plain of Peru
Peru is just south of Ecuador Ecuador
curiously is on the equator which is why
I'm told Ecuador and the coast of
Ecuador is heavily forested and jungly
why Akhil which is the C major seaport
of Ecuador is just around a river that's
just full of jungle
floating out to sea which presumably is
where the animals and birds and so forth
that go out of the Galapagos Islands
came from the flotsam Oh from the from
why Akhil area stuff that floated out to
sea and floated all the way across
halfway across the Pacific and ended up
in the Galapagos Islands but once you
get south of Ecuador the coast becomes a
desert and so you have a coastal desert
just south of the equator and it's a
narrow narrow coastal plain with beyond
Andes Mountains coming up behind it so
you're in in the equatorial zone you're
in an arid environment and this is where
civilizations develop the Chavan sieve
the civilization the Moche ultimately
the Incas are Highland peoples but they
control the people in the lowland areas
so it isn't a matter it's rain forest or
dense bush that gives rise to a
civilization in the equatorial new world
it's also a coastal desert that gives
rise to civilization in the new world
all in the equatorial zone you can take
a coastal desert in the temperate zone
let's say from Los Angeles to San Diego
and the native population there when it
was you know that we know about from
from from Europeans element we're among
some of the the least materially
advanced
people's in North America the you know
that was a desert on the coast that
really did didn't seem to be able to
support much whereas here you have a
desert on the coast improve that
supports substantial populations
substantial civilization now you could
say as people have that in Peru there is
a cold current that brings a lot of fish
and therefore you know boy a lot of
anchovies there and therefore their
civilization on the other hand of the
Portuguese tuna fleet in San Diego feels
that there's a lot of fish up in
Southern California as well so I'm not
quite sure whether fish resources
provide you're only throwing the answer
but the La Nina El Nino oscillation
affects Peru but it affects Pacific
areas in general since that oscillation
has recently been discovered projecting
it back into history has been very very
fragile because you know let's say
climate history before 1600 ad tends to
be big event climate history now a
volcano or a you know some other
dramatic occasion whereas the the
current oscillations in the Pacific
haven't been pushed that far back to the
best of my knowledge as far as I've read
into it but that would simply mean that
for those people improve there be some
bad years you know mostly good years and
then you have a change in the El Nino La
Nina oscillation and then you have some
so bad years anyway it's puzzling now if
you were to go back and read the chapter
in the earth and those peoples
that touches on Africa for the first
time my there was a chapter that it was
a chapter six I think on old
communications among people's or you
know something really gripping like that
but it dealt with the Silk Road and the
Saharan trade and Indian Ocean trade and
with the dissemination of the Bantu in
Africa my colleague fellow writer David
Northrop wrote the African piece of the
chapter and he was drawn to the to the
theory that the reason the African
polities the remain small and fragmented
and never come together into big states
is that there was so much space that if
you had some kind of population pressure
or friction you could you know Trek 20
miles off and start over and that you
didn't have a conflict that was
unavoidable because of the constraints
of the you know of the locality so he
argued that the African societies of the
of the of ancient times starting with
the Bantu migrations and continuing down
to a modern times he argued with these
societies have very very strikingly
similar cultural
aspects whether in the nature of kinship
or the nature of rule or the use of
masks or the use of music the type of
agriculture and and and he was he would
argue that they're similar because
they're all disseminating from basically
from a hearth thought to be somewhere
around around West Africa sort of the
southwest portion of the African savanna
and that they they never develop into a
urban civilization because there they
were able to manage conflict by by
separation and that each of you had
small kingdoms or chieftain ships that
would have a particular form but by and
large they did not find themselves in
unavoidable conflict situations that led
to to a conquering B C and D and setting
up a state I don't know how common that
theory is among African us today but
just taking into the hypothesis and you
look at the equatorial zone in in Africa
and you say this is one of the most
spacious areas in the world you have
essentially flat land all the way from
the Atlantic Ocean across to the to the
mountainous areas of Ethiopia and Kenya
and the and the Rift Valley of East
Africa in other words if if avoidance of
conflict through through movement and
resettlement was desirable
this is the ideal place to do it because
there is so much space the the terrain
is comparatively uniform and you could
do it doesn't mean you you did do it or
felt you had to but you could do it then
you look at the equatorial zone in the
new world and you say there's no place
in the world that has less space no
place in the world that has less space
you're confined between the Atlantic
Ocean and the Pacific Ocean if you were
in Central America and it is a heavily
mountainous area and as you move south
the mountains are very close to the
coast the Andes Mountains and the
civilization is developing in that
narrow space between the Pacific Ocean
and the Andes Mountains just as say in
lowland Mayan areas the you know it's
mountains here on the west and the south
and people are coming into essentially a
cul-de-sac
they can't there's no place to go from
the Yucatan so if you were to take this
as an explanation for Africa then you
might flip it and say you know it may be
that the reason you had civilization in
the Peruvian coast and in Central
America is because there was so little
space and people when they found
themselves in conflict conflicted they
they couldn't move anyplace when you
read works on the on the emergence of
the Maya this is not explicitly there as
a theory but rather it is implicit in
the sense that
population pressure is seen as the goad
for the development of a sophisticated
civilization with large and ornate
ceremonial centers and so forth in the
lowland Maya region no initially you
just had scattered settlements that had
some some pottery but as the population
grew there was no place to expand and
therefore it intensifies so then you
would say well if that is this week's
nutty Bullet theory what is that how do
we how will we handle that for Indonesia
that's in the tropics and it's it's
confined but you don't have elaborate
civilizations there it's confined
because it's spread out over a a whole
bunch of islands but as I as I mentioned
in earlier lecture this is where sailing
developed so that you did in fact have
people who could practice conflict
avoidance through through migration and
the theory that all of the Polynesian
islands and Melanesian territories were
settled by people originally from the
Indonesia to Philippines zone or at
least using the technologies that
disseminate from that zone you could say
well well maybe that is the equivalent
of of what you had in Africa by simply
moving from one place to another in
order to
to avoid conflict then you could say
well let's look at the temperate zones
North America of the country that we
love
America you know America the Beautiful
but America that pretty much uninhabited
it there was lots of room you know going
east and west for avoidance you can look
at Central Asia and you say well Central
Asia which has vast amounts of room it
didn't develop civilization in the same
way that the Mediterranean did well
what's the Mediterranean it's a whole
whole slew of converging mountain ranges
with Islands and they're all facing each
other you know if if you're going to
have conflict what a great place to have
conflict because every little Valley
every little island provides a kind of
an inescapable environment so when we
when we read in ancient history about
the migrations of the sea peoples the
the Hyksos who invaded Egypt are they
the Philistines who invaded the coast of
holy land
it seems naturally say well you had
conflict and so people got in their
boats and they and they left but there
was no place to go that wasn't already
inhabited and so they come and they
fight for Dominion in Libya or they
fight for Ana minyan in Israel or they
fight for Dominion in Sardinia that
simply the way things are and so you get
these tendencies towards civilization
earlier on you could say well what about
the River Valley civilizations the Indus
Valley the Tigris Euphrates the Nile
you could say well yeah there's lots of
room but it's real drunk and
you could say okay we're having revving
a conflict with you here along along
this river bank here in Iraq but we're
going to avoid the conflict we're going
to move out into the desert 20 miles and
we're going to die you know
you despite the fact that it looks on a
general map like an area of with
enormous possible for expansion
possibility for expansion ancient
Mesopotamia ancient Egypt are remarkably
constrained environments you simply
cannot know if you go to Egypt and you
stand on the desert on one side of the
Nile and you look across the Nile you
see the desert on the other side that is
the width of Egypt and everybody lives
there between those two deserts so this
would conduce toward a theory that that
lack of Laban scum the lack of space to
live in the the lack of group mobility
to serve as a to vent the pressures
caused by conflict or by overpopulation
or things like that that lack of space
conduces toward the growth of
civilization and an amplitude of space
leads to a sparse population that is
more mobile and less less given to to
the sorts of conflict that you find and
we in the civilizational areas know
this I think this is a really cool
theory now I can explain history of the
world through that through this theory
why we have civilizations some areas and
not in other areas and and I thought of
it yesterday I think oh I have to
lecture on new world this week and you
know what can I say
as someone who is you know just Bo and
ignorant on the subject what can I say
that would be new and different and I
thought well I have to draw on what I
know and that is the other parts of the
world and so I was struck in reading the
things by people who work on
pre-columbian America by how rarely they
talk about other parts of the world and
the degree to which it is a kind of not
hermetically sealed but but a
comparatively sealed study in how do you
think about the past that you don't
think in global terms you think in
hemispheric terms because you assume
that those oceans are providing an
insulation from from things that are
characteristic of humans elsewhere in
the world the common factor of course is
that people are people I mean you know
the territory may be separate but but
people do tend to do the same things
under certain circumstances where were
they they are in the world so going back
to an idea I talked about the very
beginning this course about the idea of
common denominators nobody is surprised
to find that the the pre-columbian
societies whether they were heavily
developed civilizations as you have in
the Andes and Central America or whether
they are sparsely settled areas that you
would have in temperate zones on north
and south nobody is surprised to find
that
they have art because that's what humans
do not the art looks different but
nobody is surprised when the most
developed and densely populated areas
begin to develop techniques of keeping
records nobody is surprised to find that
the calendar and astronomy proved to be
an interest in the Western Hemisphere as
they proved to be interested in eastern
hemisphere no one is surprised by
pyramids in big stone architecture in
other words the the human
characteristics seem to strike everyone
as being appropriate to the species and
yet they tend to be reluctant to look at
what that species is doing in other
places and possibly comprehend or
opposite circumstances now that brings
me to domestic animals in jared
diamond's Guns Germs and Steel up or
diamond and back on him again he
maintains that all animals all big
animals that can be domesticated were
domesticated by 2000 BC and that if you
had in the Americas big animals that
were not domesticated by 2,000 BC or
domesticated at all in his view it is
because they couldn't be this is sort of
going to the to the theory of absence of
evidences evidence of absence
what this outlook depends upon is the
notion that certain animals are prone to
domesticate that prone that's a wrong
word they are ripe for domestication and
other species are not and that comes to
be a sort of a self-fulfilling
designation if a species becomes
domestic then it was ready to be
domesticated it was hanging around he
was like this little piggy wants her
leash around his neck but if you have a
specie did not become domestic then it
couldn't become domestic the fact that
today most of the Bison in America are
domestic was an inconvenience that he
was happy to overlook the fact that the
caribou of North America which he claims
cannot be domesticated are the same
species as the reindeer of the old world
which are domestic was sort of a that
that would have been a difficult thing
to accommodate if he had bothered to put
it in the book
in other words there's a certain
selection of data to fit a preordained
theory but it's highlighted the problem
of why humans do certain things in other
words if you talk about common
denominators you can talk about humans
doing categories of things in other
words humans may have gods they may
dance they may feed themselves something
like that but but is that the same thing
as humans doing specific things will
humans try to domesticate animals and
that really is sort of the key thing
here because if you take it that that
trying to investigate animals is a
natural is a common denominator that's a
human propensity then the fact that you
didn't have any in the new world except
for the dog and the and the llama and
the turkey the guinea pig it Center the
fact you didn't have any in the new
world would indicate that the people new
world tried and failed and that does not
fit diamonds notion that all humans have
equal the equal astuteness in living in
the world that way if you're a chieftain
in New Guinea or a chieftain in
Washington DC the inequality that was
apparent in terms of your health and
power is a happenstance that says
nothing about your you know the
difference a month between us as people
so this was a problem how do you account
for the absence of of domestic animals
in the Western Hemisphere it's a
somewhat different story from the one of
big animal extinctions the big animal
extinctions the the hypothesis was that
the people who came to the new world
like the people who came to Australia
you know fifteen thousand years earlier
or the people who came to Cuba ten
thousand years later fifteen thousand
years later that the carrot they they
had a common characteristic which was
their desire to kill everything but
nobody really has postulated that that
is a universal human characteristic
indeed I think in most societies want
and killing of every animal around is
found upon it's bad for you maintenance
of the environment it's bad for
maintenance of your of your of your diet
and so forth
we do have some huge traditions of
hunting particularly for Royal hunts but
the idea that of killing everything is
has rarely been put forward as a common
human characteristic and indeed the big
animal extinction theory has been
vociferously denounced by certain
writers from the Native American
community they say don't we love the
environment we love nature we love
animals look at a folklore you know
coyote and magpie and all these
characters we are the lovers of nature
you know we show up in TV ads with a
tear in our eye when we consider the
depredations that the white people have
inflicted upon us how can you say that
we started has wanted murderers of every
animal on the continent and the
megafauna extinction people say yeah
look I have a computer program here it
shows you couldn't you could have done
it all you had to do was want to do it
and the fact that you forgot that you
wanted to do it should not absolutely
you know absence of evidence is not
evidence of absence so the there's a
problem with why were these people
different in that area and then with the
domestic animals it's it's a similar
question of why were they different with
respect to domestic animals why didn't
they domesticate the the caribou if it's
a natural thing for humans to
investigate animals why didn't they
domesticate the Bison why didn't they
domesticate the peccary you know though
the javelina the wild pigs or pig like
things they're animals around they could
have investigated the only one they
investigated was the was the Juanico
which becomes the the domestic llama
oh this gets into academic areas having
to do with the theory of domestication
I've written about this and I asked you
early on in the course to read some of
the stuff I wrote but let me just recap
it a little bit the problem with
thinking about animals becoming domestic
is that if you have no domestic animals
you don't know that an animal can be
domestic you don't know that that's an
option and if you moreover if you have
one domestic animal you don't
necessarily know that it is a domestic
variant of an animal that otherwise you
know is a wild animal in other words if
you have a piggy that is eating garbage
in your village and you go out to hunt
wild boar do you really think that the
piggy evolved from the wild boar if you
do then your name was Charles Darwin and
you were there thousands of years before
your later namesake invented evolution
the idea that one species can turn into
another was a not an acceptable idea
through most of human history so that
even when you had domestic species
unless they were virtually
interchangeable with the wild guess a
would be the case with reindeer you
wouldn't even know that where it came
from the reason is that it takes
generations of genetic separation a
reproductive separation from wild stock
in order for the paynus characteristic
of domestic animals
become expressed in a genetic fashion
taming an animal you can take an animal
from the wild you can raise it from a
pup or a cub or a fallen or whatever and
it can be the most tame thing imaginable
and you know Wow sexual maturity hits
and it's a wild animal just like humans
the the maturing process produces huge
increases in adrenaline and fight and
flight fight or flight responses things
like that and the only thing that's
going to change that is some sort of
genetic suppression of those of those
characteristics either through a
preservation into adulthood of juvenile
characteristics which is what you see
with pigs and dogs with they're pushed
in juvenile faces and there are other
examples that are you that are given no
floppy ears for example as opposed to
the the rekt ears of wolves so you can
have a continuation of juvenile
characteristics or you can simply have a
genetic changes that that favor very low
production of of adrenaline and related
hormones among adult animals studies
done in the 20th century of the
domestication of foxes the investigation
of rats have shown that after 20 or 30
generations of reproductive isolation
those foxes are rats that have survived
you know through this repeated process
of of domesticating within the group
have adrenaline glands that will be say
a quarter the weight of the adrenaline
glands of the wild animals that they
started with
and when such an animal becomes angry
you know hostels ready to bite or fight
or something like that it just can't
keep the anger well it just it doesn't
sustain the the characteristics of the
wild animal
oddly enough animals that that inherit
calm characteristics once they become
domestic seem to have an extremely high
reproduction rate in comparison with the
wild stock my sense from studies I've
done is that based on the not signs I
doubt they're based on the studies I've
read about with the foxes and the rats
is that animals that are penned up are
so agitated all the time that they can't
have sex that they simply don't have any
offspring at all because it's very hard
to be really really really wild and have
sex I'm this is do not try it yourself
this was a close
professional driver on a closed course
but but you know you think about it and
you know when you're absolutely furious
you know and you want to hit someone
that isn't the time to make out and
supposing you're a wild animal that's
living in a high predation environment
where you know they're Eagles or Hawks
there are foxes there are hyenas there
are all sorts of things around ready to
eat you you don't have a terribly high
reproduction rate and yet those who are
laid back are eaten so they don't
reproduce at all so in the wild in high
predation environment
it is the the wild the wildest one's
survived but have comparatively low
reproduction rates whereas the calm ones
are eaten before they reach maturity and
do not contribute their column genes to
the gene pool but if they had survived
they would be more capable of
reproducing than otherwise so some
people in steadily who have studied the
the big animal extinction rates say you
know the difference is in the rate of
reproduction that the animals that
disappeared were those that have low
reproduction rates and those that
survived were those with high
reproduction rates and that it was a
wasn't killing so much as you know any
any combination of stressful factors
affected some species more than others
and that that sort of stands to reason
that you would have a big difference and
that gets to the issue of the Juanico
down in South America the early
descriptions that you get not even so
early of explorers that go down into
Argentina and other places that have
large numbers of Juana COEs this is an
animal related to the camel they observe
that this is an animal that lives out in
the desert it doesn't have predators
around same thing with camels and
certain other desert animals in the in
the old world they they did not they
were not subject to a high predation
level and you have these interesting
descriptions where where you'll have a a
male Juanico surrounded by his 20 female
wanna collapse and you know the intrepid
explorer comes up and shoots the male
Juanico and the ladies and around
menacing waiting to see what's going to
happen next they don't run away and the
one codes were notoriously curious look
people I wonder what they're doing
I'll just go over here and hang out and
look at them and so on and this is a
disposition that I call tame in the wild
where you have a wild animals that are
comparatively tame comparatively tame
and these become easily brought under
human control so that elephants at the
top of the food chain have no predators
they are comparatively tame even though
they are wild so that all of these
so-called domestic elephants of South
Asia
none of them are brought up in captivity
they're simply captured and unused
because they don't care their elephants
you know you want me to pull a log I'll
pull log what the hell camels I think
were we're taming the wild they have no
go predators at least one up camels of
Arabia if you go to the Galapagos
Islands you see this dramatically none
of the animals have any fight-or-flight
response at all you say oh I want to I
want to walk at the end of the room but
there are a thousand marine iguanas
sunning themselves on the rocks between
here in the end of the room shoo shoo go
away green iguanas nothing
if you walk forward they'll inch apart
so you don't step on them but it never
occurs to them to get out of your way
but eventually you've made your way
through the sea of marine iguanas same
thing with the birds you walk up to a
nest
you know blue footed boobie is nesting
and you look at it it looks at you what
kind of movie are you
I'm City Oden s what are you doing
that's useful and this phenomenon of
tame in the wild is is actually fairly
fairly widespread but I think it
explains why you have that one animal
that makes it because it's not a you
know domestic animals are do not
represent a natural human propensity
change animals now why certain species
became domestic in certain areas in my
view has comparable a little to do with
not clear a little bit has something to
do with what the species was and its
species characteristics that has a lot
to do with what is the purpose of of
keeping the animals captive and there is
where I would talk about sacrificing
animals ceremonial killing and of course
in the New World
you didn't need domestic animals for
that because you had people so I will
say something about sacrificing humans
and playing ball to very closely related
things on Thursday